the invisible election isn't just about
political parties activities or what
unknown third parties get up to as well
Sky News has uncovered the existence of
previously unknown botnets networks of
automated social media accounts
spreading political messages
and we've tracked how they've been
influencing the election through
thousands of tweets the botnets that
we've picked up were tweeting the same
thing at the same time that's very
stupid bots which tweet hundreds of
thousands of times per day are also very
stupid are very easy to pick up they can
be very effective at shutting down
debate we collaborated with the center
of the analysis of social media to look
into BOTS
during this election if you're trying to
be a real person and pretend that you're
real person you need to employ some
quite sophisticated tactics to get
people to believe that you are indeed
just concerned about Jeremy Corbyn or
politics in Britain according to the
research the bots in this election have
been small-scale and subtle hard to tell
from humans that compares with a much
larger scale sledgehammer approach in
other campaigns in 2014 in Mexico the
government used around 75,000 BOTS to
tweet spam material and drown out
protests in Russia after the
assassination of opposition politician
Boris Nemtsov BOTS were used to spread
misinformation about who is behind the
killing and all around the world BOTS
have been used by politicians to make
them seem much more popular than they
actually are
we call it computational propaganda it's
the combination of a computer program
that gets a message out to thousands of
thousands of users with some piece of
junk news or some some fake facts that
have been made up that try to poison
conversations the problem with BOTS
isn't necessarily someone with a lot of
computing power cranking their servers
to swing an election it's
the uncertainty they so you might think
that you're speaking to an authentic
unique online voice but perhaps you're
chatting to automated software in stay
in undermines the credibility of
everyone when you can't answer the
simple question BOTS or not throughout
this campaign we've tried to uncover the
hidden digital techniques of modern
political persuasion the pause will be
the visible result of this most
invisible election Tom Cheshire Sky News